The Joe Rogan experience.
We were talking before, this has so much to talk about,
but we were talking before, and you were saying that, uh, over the last year,
you almost died because you had some crazy internal and, uh,
you had an aneurysm in your pancreas.
Yeah. I had an undiagnosed asymptomatic aneurysm,
which is a sort of ballooning in the blood vessel, uh, in the artery,
in my pancreatic artery and out of the blue, it was a congenital thing.
Like I apparently had developed during my whole life. It, um, it was just from a
structural problem and, uh, and one afternoon, one beautiful June afternoon,
last year at burst. And, um, you know,
I just felt this pain shoot through my stomach. I was like, what is that?
And within a few minutes I couldn't stand up. And within about 10 minutes,
I was started go blind.
And my wife called the ambulance. And, um, those guys got there and,
and, um, you know,
I was tanking really fast and the hospital is an hour away and
I, by a miracle, I don't even think the doctors understand it, but by a miracle,
I was still alive. When I got to the hospital,
I lost 90% of my blood into my abdomen. Um, and,
um, I didn't know I was dying,
but I was dying and I was right in that sort of Twilight zone. And, um,
the, uh, uh,
black pit opened up underneath me and I felt myself starting to get pulled down
into it. And I, I didn't want to go,
like it was cold and dark and black and bottomless. I just knew like,
do not go down there. I was getting pulled down into it.
And right at that moment,
my father who passed away in 2012, um, my father, uh,
sort of appeared next to me and started trying to communicate,
trying to communicate with me and comforting me. And, um, I, um,
I sort of waved him away. And the last thing I remember saying to the doctor,
I was sort of losing consciousness. And the last thing I said to the doctor was,
you're losing me right now. You got to hurry. He was trying to put it,
he'd cut my neck open. And he was trying to put a line into my neck too.
You know, they pumped 10, 10 units of blood into me.
And that's what brought me back. It was really close.
Um, when you say you, you felt you were sinking into a pit, like,
do we sing this?
I, I, I, I mean, you know, your perceptions are very weird. Cause I, you know,
very little oxygen in the brain. I had a hemoglobin count of 1.2.
If you're a doctor, you know what that is, it's almost unheard of.
And so I just felt this pit underneath me and it was pulling me into it and I
didn't want to go. You can see a pit. Yeah. I mean, again,
see slash feel your perceptions are very weird when you're like that.
And then my father also was sort of floating above me. He was a presence. Um,
I don't know if seeing him as quite the word it's another perception.
Wow.
Yeah. So coming out of that, once you were your health,
he must have had an incredible new found appreciation for all the people in your
life and just everything.
It was a long path, you know, I mean, I'm a really healthy guy later.
The doctor said, you know, it was your, you know,
I was a marathon runner when I was young and um, I don't drink, um,
I am athletic and I use my body pretty vigorously. And he said,
that saved your life. Like you didn't have a heart attack. Like you, you,
you owe your life to that. Wow. But the next morning, you know,
I didn't know whether I'd almost died. I had no idea. I have two little girls.
I have a four year old and a one and a half year old.
And they're the most precious things to me. I mean,
I can't even describe it obviously.
And the fact that they almost lost their dad was just devastating.
When the ICU nurse came in and said, how are you doing Mr. Younger?
You're one lucky guy. You almost died yesterday. I had no idea.
And then she came back an hour later and, um, and, and she said,
how you doing? And I said, you know, physically, you know,
I was throwing up blood.
I was not feeling it was not doing very well physically, but I said, I was,
I said, but you know, I'm really struggling with what you told me. And, um,
it's really terrifying. I didn't know. And I mean, I said,
I almost died in my own driveway in front of my family. And I didn't even know,
like I said, I keep thinking about it. I can't stop.
And she said the wisest things, one of the wisest things I've ever heard,
she said, um, she said,
stop thinking of that moment as scary and start thinking of it as sacred.
And she didn't elaborate. She didn't need to. And the next five days in the ICU,
I thought about the word sacred and what the experience was
now giving me access to, and you know,
not to sound sort of trite, but, um,
life is a frigging miracle and you know, I'm not religious. I, you know,
whatever, I, I don't think any of us, few of us,
I certainly didn't quite understand, um,
what a miracle it is that we're alive. That we exist, that we draw breath,
that we can think about ourselves,
that we're here for even one day is a freaking miracle.
And you can forget that because you, life gets busy.
And all of a sudden, I felt like life was sorta returned to me,
meaning that I understood how sacred it is. And, um, again,
I'm an atheist, I don't mean sacred in a religious sense. I mean,
in the sense that it's has a profound value and you mustn't, mustn't,
mustn't forget.
It's so easy to lose sight of that when you're caught up in your bills or
traffic or your. And yeah, there's so much,
so much of life that is essential in order for you to just
keep on existing in society, but not really important.
Yeah. And you know, we're humans, we're, you know,
we're wired to have react to things, you know, someone you off or you're,
you're tired. It's not that we shouldn't have those reactions.
Those reactions also keep us alive. I mean, our emotional,
physical reactions are adaptive and they protect us. Right.
But at the end of the day,
you don't want them to run away with your experience of life.
You want to reclaim it and just go, right. You know,
all I have to do is go back to that moment of what happened in that driveway and
that I was spared getting pulled into that pit that didn't happen.
And my daughter's got to have a father.
I get to experience whatever the rest of my life is, whatever it is,
who knows how long I'll live, but I get, I, that gift was returned to me. Um,
and I don't even, I don't even know who to say, thank you to, uh,
other than I've started giving blood 10, 10 people,
10 people donated blood and saved my life.
And I'll never know who they are and that, um, you know,
it makes you part of this sort of web of life, um,
in a way that it's, you know, what I gave blood for the first time, you know,
like after this happened, I gave blood and I've made me feel so good. Uh,
and now I can't wait to do it again. Like you're,
I'm part of something bigger and that's one of the most profound human joys is
to be part of something greater than yourself. So.
This, this experience, um, that you.
How long did it take you before you were fully recovered? Well, you know, I had,
I had a, you know, a gallon of blood in my abdomen and, and well,
whatever that amount of blood in your body, something like that, they can't,
you know, it's a hematoma and my body had to gradually reabsorb it. Uh,
so you know, that takes months. And, uh,
and now I'm left with this sort of psychological residue of the experience,
which is I have this, um, uh, I, you know, renewed,
reinvigorated appreciation for life. Um,
but also the re the truth about life is that none of us know
for sure we're going to be alive at sunset. You know, I mean,
we all know you can get cancer, or you can die in a car accident or whatever,
but really the truth is the thing that we're alive,
because the tiniest membranes in your body are, are, are,
are not rupturing. You know what I mean?
Like the system that your body is like incredibly complex,
and if something goes wrong,
you can be dead in minutes and you can be totally healthy and that can happen.
And the fact that the universe can just randomly take you out for
no apparent reason. Um, that's pretty startling news.
If you think about it, I didn't know.
It worked that way and it can make you kind of paranoid.
Did it make you paranoid? Oh, totally. Yeah. I mean, I just,
every day I was like, I mean, this is gradually going away, but I just,
I realized, like, you don't know,
you just don't know that you're going to be alive in an hour where I'm now,
and you're going running,
you're reading a book to your daughter or your whatever,
having dinner with some friends. And now I know like an hour from now,
I could be dead or the guy I'm talking to could be dead and none of us know,
and none of us can do anything about it. And that's just what life is. We're,
we're, we're living on a rock hurtling through the universe. I mean, we're,
we're, we're part of the universe and we exist that it's, um,
and it's mercy really.
Will you afterwards contemplating what that pit was and what it means and
what it means to slide into that.
And like, you know, I started to do a little research into the death.
I want to write a book about this. I think I'm going to call it pulse. Ooh,
right. The thing that keeps us alive and why we're alive and,
and what happens when you die.
And I've just started doing some research into this. And, and th the, the, the,
the visitation by aunt dead ancestors is very common for people.
Um, and often, um, I mean,
there's all kinds of reasons that you might hallucinate when your brain is low
on oxygen, but I, you know, I didn't loosen to it. Anyone in my family,
I didn't elusive, I, my dead father. Right. And that's very, very common.
And I didn't know I was dying.
So it's not like I conjured them up because I knew I was headed somewhere. Uh,
I was very confused and there,
he was trying to comfort me and that's a really common experience.
So I looked into it. And so they have, they have all these, you know,
release of ketamine and like,
they have all these DMT and they have all these sort of neurochemical
explanations for the subjective experience of dying for the
person. And, you know,
we only know this because people come back like I do and report what they saw.
And it's usually pretty weird, but it's pretty weird in predictable ways.
Like a lot of people see the dead it's as if they show up to help.
And I want to repeat, I'm an atheist. I'm not religious.
I don't believe in anything. And my dad was a physicist.
So I want to sort of explain what happens in ways that he would, um,
respect scientifically. And so,
one of the things they said is that you can take a low oxygen, ketamine,
all these things that physically could happen in their brain. You can,
you can subject, uh, a healthy person to those things,
and they don't have the same kinds of hallucinations.
Those hallucinations are particular only to the dying. And I want to know,
I want to try to figure out what is going on in that weird twilight's.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Jerry on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan.